[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANA HOFFMAN: Hi,
I'm Dana, an engineer
at Google working on Google
Cloud Platform and open source
integrations.
PADDY FORAN: And I'm Paddy,
an engineer at HashiCorp
on the Terraform team.
Terraform is a tool
that lets you provision
your infrastructure
on any cloud,
or even across multiple clouds,
in a safe, easy to manage way.
DANA HOFFMAN: In
the last two videos
you saw demos of Vagrant
development environments
with Google Compute
Engine, and Packer,
for producing Compute
Engine images.
We're going to pick up where we
left off last time with using
Packer to create
a Compute Engine
image with our
80s-style arcade game,
Hyperspace, pre-installed
and ready to go.
Continuing our story, our
game has neared completion.
And now we're getting
ready for our big launch.
But because we know our
game is going to be viral,
we want to make sure that
we can handle the load.
So rather than run Hyperspace
on a single compute instance,
and hope that it can handle
thousands of players,
we're going to take advantage
of the architecture.
And create one image with
the front end web server
and a separate image
with the back end server.
And I had to do
for that was make
some customizations to my
Hyperspace install scripts.
And use Packer to create
two images instead
of the single all-in-one image
you saw in the last video.
So now that we have a scalable
way to package Hyperspace,
let's talk about
how we can deploy it
to Google Cloud Platform.
Paddy, any idea how we
should go about that?
PADDY FORAN: Actually Dana, I
think I know just the thing.
Today we're going use
another HashiCorp tool called
Terraform, to help us deploy
Hyperspace with this new split
front end and back end approach.
Terraform is a tool
that allows you
to write declarative
configuration
files describing the state
of your infrastructure.
It allows to provision resources
such as VMs, disks, networking
configurations, and databases.
And it works with
many Cloud providers,
including Google Cloud Platform.
But you already knew
that, right Dana?
DANA HOFFMAN: Yeah,
you could say I'm
pretty familiar with Terraform.
I'm the lead engineer at
Google working on our Terraform
integration with
Google Cloud Platform.
We've heard from plenty
of our customers,
that they really
like using Terraform
to manage GCP and appreciate
that Terraform has support
for multiple cloud providers.
With Terraform, users can
manage GCP resources spanning
many of our products such
as Compute Engine, Cloud
Storage, IM, Cloud SQL,
CLOUD DNS, et cetera.
But for this demo, we're going
to focus on Compute Engine.
So let's get started.
PADDY FORAN: The first
thing you want to do
is go to terraform.io
and download
the software for your platform.
Refer back to the
Vagrant and Packer videos
for setting up your GCP project.
For this demo we're going to
use Terraform from an existing
Google Compute Engine instance.
Navigating to the
list of GC images,
you can see that I already
have two separate images.
One for the front end
and one for the back.
OK, before we step through
Terraform config file,
let's show you how
to use Terraform plan
to see what resources
Terraform will create.
In this case we don't have
any of our infrastructure
provisioned.
And as you can see, Terraform
is expecting provisions
to set them new resources
with zero changes and zero
deletions.
When we're happy with what
we expect Terraform to do,
we can then run Terraform
apply to perform
the actual infrastructure
provisioning.
While that's provisioning let's
walk through that configuration
file.
This first section of the
file contains the GCP project
parameters.
I haven't specified a service
account key in this example,
because I'm running Terraform
on a Compute Engine instance.
And Terraform is smart
enough to pull credentials
from the metadata service.
Next, you see I have a resource
specifying my back end GC
virtual machine instance,
including the name, zone
location, and machine type.
Here is the snippet
where I've specified
that I want this instance
to use the back end
image built with Packer.
Skipping down to the stanza
for our front end VM instances,
you can see that I've specified
the other package image.
But we want three
of these instances.
So we need to set
its count to three.
I'm also provisioning
a GCU load balancer
using a target pool
and forwarding rule.
Using the output parameter, I
can tell Terraform to print out
the load balancers
virtual IP address when
it's completed provisioning
all of our resources.
DANA HOFFMAN: Flipping
back to the other terminal,
you can see that Terraform
has indeed finished
provisioning our resources.
And here's the front end IP.
Let's put that IP
address into our browser
and see what happens.
PADDY FORAN: It works, awesome.
DANA HOFFMAN: Yay.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PADDY FORAN: OK well
let's go ahead and delete
all of these resources.
We can easily do that
with Terraform destroy.
DANA HOFFMAN: So that
wraps up the demo.
While we only showed you
a subset of GCP services
in the demo, there's
enough I think for you
to get started with the others.
So Paddy, how do users get
started of a Terraform?
PADDY FORAN: Simple enough Dana.
Just go to terraform.io
check out the docs,
and keep track of our
github repository, where
we're constantly adding new
GCP resources to Terraform.
This has been fun Dana,
and I've really enjoyed
working with you on Terraform.
DANA HOFFMAN: Thanks Paddy, I've
enjoyed working with you too.
And I'm looking forward
to adding new resources
and features over time.
Thanks to all of you
for watching us today.
We hope you give
Terraform and GCP a try.
And don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
so you can catch the next video
in the HashiCorp corp series.
Thanks for watching
make sure to check out
some other videos in this
series as well as the playlist
and don't forget to subscribe.